what's up guys bang bang happy New Year
Bitcoin starting off the year pretty
flat and that actually might be a good
thing if we go all the way back to
November of 2021 Bitcoin to hit an
all-time high of 69 000 nice and then it
proceeded to fall 75 that's where it
sits today but if you actually think
about the last couple of months in this
industry we have seen blow up after blow
up after blow up and there's been all
sorts of Carnage chaos uncertainty and
lots and lots of the Legacy finance and
tech industry leaving and saying I'm
done with that well if Bitcoin just
continue to hold around fifteen or
sixteen thousand dollars that actually
shows a great deal of strength we know
that Bitcoin is just over 300 billion
dollar market cap and we also can see
that ninety percent of the supply has
been issued into circulation and so if
so many people over 65 percent of
bitcoiners are just holding on to their
Bitcoin they're not moving those coins
that are actually sitting out there in
circulation that means that it's an
illiquid asset and there's not that much
price elasticity so naturally Bitcoin
going sideways although there's tons of
bad news is somewhat kind of a sign of
strength in a weird way and so then we
can go ahead and we can look forward in
2023 what should we expect well we know
that inflation continues to be at over
seven percent in the United States and
high inflation is persisting around the
world the Federal Reserve for over a
year now has talked about destroying
demand and creating tighter Financial
conditions and they've raised interest
rates at a historic rate and also
started to try to conduct quantitative
tightening well as they have done that
inflation has stuck around and been much
stickier than they ever intended it to
be and so now we're stuck with a
stagflationary period where the Federal
Reserve is actually trying to raise
interest rates and create those tighter
Financial conditions but we're not
growing we've seen time and time and
time again that the Federal Reserve
things that they've knocked out
inflation but it's not happening and now
we're getting into a bad situation where
there is compound annual growth rate of
over seven percent there is no way that
the average American family is going to
be able to survive for much longer in
this type of environment and so with
inflation raging on and the FED
remaining committed to bring it under
control Bitcoin continues to go sideways
because we have to remember that markets
are forward-looking Bitcoin ran
aggressively hundreds of percent before
inflation hit and then when investors
saw that the Fed was going to try to
destroy demand and bring inflation under
control bitcoin's price fell
aggressively as well my expectation is
that it's going to be a pretty rough
year in 2023 for the economy many
investors are predicting a full-on
recession I'd argue we're already in one
and if the FED continues to create those
tighter Financial conditions and they
don't pivot back to loose monetary
policy it wouldn't surprise me if
Bitcoin just kind of goes sideways for
the year now I'm not much for Bitcoin
predictions anymore and I tend to think
that the average investor is simply
going to keep dollar cost averaging into
whatever their favorite asset is we know
that Warren Buffett and Charlie Munger
people who aren't fans of Bitcoin but
they do have a great great track record
as investors they like to just dollar
cost average into great assets and hold
them forever well the Modern Age We
simply call that huddling that's what a
lot of bitcoiners do and so I hope that
your Year is off to a great start in
2023 Bitcoins fundamentals continue to
look strong yes there are all sorts of
problems like gbtc's discount being down
over 50 percent which is quite
surprising to a lot of folks but
bitcoin's core fundamentals things like
hash rate fees and transactions continue
to be a bright light I'm excited about
2023 and I hope you are as well I will
see you all next Saturday